okay
thank you everyone for being here this
afternoon
I'm Lieutenant Pamela Castro with the
Carter Springs Police Department I'm the
public information officer for the
police department
just like yesterday I wanted to start
out touching base on some information
that we have already shared make sure
everybody has that information hopefully
all of you have seen that we sent out a
news release earlier today with some
updated information about the victims in
this case
as of noon today we released that we
have five deceased community members
that has not changed since yesterday
we have 17 community members who are
injured because of a gun gunshot wound
we have one Community member who is
injured but not because of a gunshot
wound and we have one Community member
who was a victim with no visible
injuries this final area is the area
that we expect numbers to change and
that's why we have reached out to the
community to all of our Media Partners
to get out there that we know there were
more people at the club and we really
want to speak to them they could be
victims of a crime and so we are looking
to talk to them and identify them if at
all possible
the FBI has been a great partner through
this and they have set up a tip line for
us anybody with information if they were
there they have video they were driving
by they might know information about the
suspect anything at all no matter how
small or insignificant they believe it
might be
could we please call and let us know
about that
that phone number is 1-800 call FBI and
they have dedicated people who are there
to talk to anybody who calls in
today we are going to
um have a couple of speakers I want to
go through the order of the speakers for
you again if the conclusion of this if
there's any spelling of names that you
need we will be happy to get that to you
the first Speaker today will be Carter
Springs Police Department chief Adrian
Vasquez
the second speaker will be Carter
Springs Mayor John suthers
the third speaker will be Colorado
Fourth Judicial District Attorney
Michael Allen and our final speaker will
be United States Attorney Cole Finnegan
I also want to acknowledge our law
enforcement fire and medical Partners
who are present today and have been
supporting us and our community from the
beginning
they are FBI acting special agent in
charge Matt Fodor
ATF Denver field division special agent
in charge David S booth
Carter Springs Fire Department chief
Randy Royal and Penrose Hospital CEO
Patrick Sharp
at the conclusion of the designated
speakers there will be a chance to ask
questions the questions will
be should be focused on what we are
sharing today or what we have previously
shared please understand that this is an
ongoing criminal investigation and out
of respect for the judicial process
there are simply things that we just
can't share information on
first up to speak will be Carter Springs
Police Department chief Adrian Vasquez
thank you everybody for being here to
cover this incredibly important event
just a horrific and sad and tragic event
today I just want to talk a little bit
about some of the victims in this
incident you know too often Society
loses track of the victims of these sad
and tragic events in all the talk about
the suspect
we strive to give the victims the
dignity and respect that they deserve
as well as Shine the Light of public
attention on the victims therefore we
are identifying them now
please know that while all of the
victims families have been notified they
are suffering a horrific loss
so I ask everyone who is listening to
keep them in your thoughts and show them
the care and heartfelt compassion that
they deserve
none of the families want to do media
interviews at this time and I ask
everyone to respect their request
we respect all of our community members
including our lgbtq community
therefore we will be identifying the
victims by how they identify themselves
and how their families have loved and
identified them
the first person I'll identify is Kelly
loving
Kelly's pronouns are she her
Daniel Aston
Daniel's pronouns are he him
Derek rump
Derek Derek's pronouns are he him
Ashley Paul that's p-a-u-g-h
Ashley's pronouns are she her
Raymond Green Vance
Raymond's pronouns are he him
I wanted to ensure that every victim
family member and Friends of victims and
all of our community members know that
our officers and detectives will
continue to be diligent and thorough in
our work to hold the suspects
accountable for these horrendous acts I
also want to reiterate that the Colorado
Springs Police Department and that I am
standing beside you as we move through
and come to a conclusion in the
investigation and seek justice for all
of our victims
as I end I ask that everyone in our
community and around the world honor
each victim lived I want to take a
moment of silence to honor those
community members who lost a loved one
please join me in a moment of silence
thank you
I also want to identify the two Heroes
who intervened inside of Club Q
their exact actions are part of the
investigation so we can't discuss the
specifics out of respect for the
judicial process but with their
permission we want to acknowledge their
heroic actions they are Thomas James and
Richard Fierro
again thank you for being here and
covering this incredibly important event
and with that I'd like to introduce
Mayor John suthers
thank you Chief and good afternoon thank
you for being here
as mayor of Colorado Springs and frankly
on behalf of all the citizens of
Colorado Springs I want to again express
our heartful condolences and unwavering
support to the victims their families
the lgbtq plus community and everyone
affected by this tragedy
I had the opportunity before I came here
today to talk to Richard Fierro
identified as one of the two Heroes that
subdued
uh the suspect in this case and in my
opinion I think the opinion of everyone
involved saved a lot of lives
um I won't talk about you know the
nature of what he told me about the
incident I will just simply talk about I
have never encountered a person who had
engaged in such heroic actions that were
so humble about it he simply said to me
I was trying to protect my family
I would also like to thank our community
the whole Colorado Springs Community the
whole Pikes Peak region for the
outpouring of support they've shown I
can't tell you how many people have
reached out from the city our region and
frankly from across the country
expressing their love and support for
Cairo Springs and the Club Q community
and speaking of the Club Q Community we
are joined here today by two co-owners
of the club Matthew Haynes and Nick
geiseka
thank you for being here and thank you
for the support you've shown uh and the
cooperation you've shown in making sure
that you help us reach out to the
community and help us serve the ends of
Justice in this case
a lot of people are wanting to know how
they can help
we know that the victims and their
families need are immediate and
long-term support
and I want to talk tell you about the
Colorado healing fund that's a fund
that's been in existence for some time
actually it was utilized during the
boulder tragedy where several people
were killed in Boulder some time ago
uh it's set up to provide a secure way
to donate to victims and family members
in incidents such as this and they are
ready and able and they've already
talked about appropriating money
existing in the fund uh to the Club Q
shooting victims
um and what I want to emphasize the
public is that if you choose to donate
through the Colorado healing fund at
coloradohealingfund.com you can be
absolutely assured the public your
donations are going to the right place
now for people needing support during
this emotional time the Colorado Springs
Police Department is hosting a community
resource Expo to provide our community
members with the help they need in
navigating the variety of emotions they
may be experiencing surrounding this
event
that Expo is being held at the
University of Colorado Colorado Springs
Kevin O'Neill cyber security and
Research Center at 360 50 North Nevada
Avenue it's open today until 7 pm and
Tuesday and Wednesday from 8 A.M to 7
P.M the Expo is providing Mental Health
Resources spiritual support emotional
support
animal support child care emergency
Financial Resources
lgbtq plus support meals and other
services basically whatever any person
adversely impacted by this incident
whatever their needs are they can help
in supporting their their needs
uh the event is designed to be an
inclusive and safe space for all
community members to gather grieve and
obtain the support they need to cope
during this difficult time
if you need this I'm speaking to the
public please take advantage of this
resource you can find details about both
the Colorado healing fund and the
community resource Expo along with other
resources at Colorado
springs.gov slash Club Q I'll repeat
that
collarsprings.gov forward slash Club Q
again on behalf of the City of Colorado
Springs I want to thank everyone for the
outpouring of support
we all
want to ensure that our community is not
defined by this tragedy but by our
response to it thank you very much now
I'll introduce Michael Allen the
district attorney of the Fourth Judicial
District
good afternoon everyone and again thank
you all for being here the devastation
this violence act has had in our
community cannot be measured
but we do know that we will respond to
it in a strong way that we will hold
people accountable as we identify
um What charges should be filed in this
case
it's imperative to note that the
investigation continues and will likely
last for some time it's very common in
homicide cases that the investigation
continues clear up to and sometimes even
during a trial in front of a jury and
that will likely be the case here
there have been reports in the media and
in the public that charges have been
filed that is not true any any case like
this an arrest warrant will be written
up that is supported by a probable cause
affidavit and that will be submitted to
a judge for approval of the arrest of a
suspect that has occurred here in this
case
any charges that are associated with an
arrest warrant are only preliminary
charges
it's also very customary and it is the
case here that the arrest warrant and
accompanying PC affidavit is sealed that
is to protect the investigation to make
sure that we have a strong investigation
that we have the ability to proceed
forward with a strong prosecution at
some point in the coming days that seal
will be lifted in the arrest warrant in
PC affidavit will be available to the
public and to the media
once the case is transferred to us for
formal charging we will review the
evidence and then determine final
charges it is also very customary that
final charges may be different than what
is in the arrest affidavit typically
there will be more charges in a case
like this when we do formal charging
than what is actually listed in the
arrest affidavit so don't be surprised
when you see a different list of charges
when we finally file formal charges with
the court
once the suspect is released from the
hospital
uh we will have a first appearance
schedule with the court that should
happen in the next couple of days I
would guess although that is still to be
determined by uh his care providers at
the hospital
that appearance will be uh by video so
he will be in the jail and be appearing
by video
we will advise the suspect at that time
of the arrest charges and his bond
status
he is being held without bond so he will
not have the opportunity to be bonded
out
within a few days of that first
appearance is when we will return to the
courtroom and file the formal charges
with the court that'll again be another
Bond advisement by the court as well as
potential punishments that the suspect
will be facing as it relates to the
charges that we file from the DA's
office
it's important to note that we are not
going to try this case in the media we
will only share information that we can
share and that is not to cause
frustration in the community or deprive
the media of information that the public
absolutely wants it is to protect that
prosecution effort we have an interest
in making sure that any conviction we
achieve in a case like this can
withstand the appeal process so we'll be
very careful about the information that
we share at least as it relates to the
DA's office but that obligation that we
have ethically extends to the
investigation team as well so oftentimes
when when you ask questions of them and
they defer and say that they can't
answer it or because it's they're trying
to protect the investigation that's
because my obligation of being tight
with the information extends to the
investigation team as well so don't hold
that against them you can hold that
against me at this point I would turn it
over to U.S attorney Cole Finnegan thank
you
thank you
on behalf of the United States
attorney's office and the Department of
Justice
we want to express our deepest
sympathies and condolences
to the victims
and to their families
and to all those who are part of the
awful incidents
roughly 36 hours ago at Club Q
we are committed to working with
district attorney Michael Allen Mayor
John suthers Chief Vasquez
local law enforcement and our federal
partners
to bring Justice
to the people who suffered
in this instance and to bring Justice
to those um
those people who are all involved this
is an awful moment
and we Pledge on behalf of our office
and the Department of Justice
that we will work as hard as we can
to find Justice in this instance thank
you
hopefully I can cut off a couple of
questions with these answers so a couple
of things moving forward for everybody
to be aware of as you've heard multiple
times this is still an ongoing
investigation we expect to be at the
scene for the forthcoming days it's not
going to be over quickly it is going to
be done thoroughly and appropriately
we'll continue to partner with our
federal Partners throughout this process
currently
people who have vehicles in the parking
lot will start receiving phone calls
from our detectives to release those
vehicles to the registered owners if
those Vehicles belongs to victims then
we will use our Victim Advocacy unit and
detectives to work with those families
if somebody is the registered owner of a
vehicle they know that they left there
and they are not contacted or they had
loaned that vehicle to somebody else you
can call us at the cross Springs Police
Department's non-emergency line which is
719-444-7000 and a detective will touch
base with you to make sure we get that
car returned to that registered owner
additionally at the conclusion of this
conference we will be releasing pictures
of the victims
that were provided by the family these
are the pictures that the family would
like to be released so that everybody
remembers them as they remember them
that will be done through our social
media accounts so you'll be able to get
the high quality pictures there
that is all of the information we have
to share at this point in time
I'll open it up to questions and then
we'll pick the most appropriate person
just be patient there's a lot of people
here and to make sure that everybody who
is watching knows what the question is
asked I will go ahead and repeat it or
if one of the other individuals comes up
to answer it we will repeat it before we
provide that answer so uh we'll start
this way sir
where
there's some interaction with
the lead why wasn't the red flag law
pursued
before this happened yes sir so the
question was about prior interactions
with police in our red flag law I will
let Mr Allen our district attorney
answer that
thank you for that question this is
going to be a very unsatisfying answer
as it relates specifically to part of
your question the red flag question is
something that I think none of us up
here are are in a position to answer but
as it relates to the first part of your
question I want to talk about this in in
a way that hopefully makes sense to
everybody
um Colorado has very restrictive
ceiling laws what that means is that if
a case is filed in a courtroom in the
state of Colorado and is dismissed for
any reason whether that is because the
prosecution dismisses it or the court
dismisses it it is automatically sealed
that is a change in the law that
occurred back in 2019 so only a three
years ago
that same statute requires us to give
very specific answers to questions about
uh cases that may or may not be under a
seal order under the scenario that I
just gave you that statute requires us
to say in response to questions about it
that no such record exists so when you
ask questions about specific prior
instances that will be our specific
answer but I want to give you a reason
why that's the answer that we're giving
I acknowledge that it is very
unsatisfying at this point hopefully at
some point in the near future we can
share more about that but at this stage
that's the best we can give you and
that's going to be the same answer for
everybody up here it's really the design
behind that is to protect persons that
have been accused of crime and been
charged and then are the case is
dismissed the idea behind it is that
that person shouldn't have to carry that
charge around with them for the rest of
their lives if there's no way to uh to
convict them of that charge that's the
design behind it I know that's an
unsatisfying answer but that's the
status of the law as it exists right now
if it changes to that specific thing
that you're asking about I'll be passing
that information out
yeah yeah so the mayor just brought up a
good point and it relates to the red
flag law the DA's office doesn't play a
part in the red flag law uh that would
be up to a law enforcement agency that's
why I say nobody in this group can
really answer that specific question it
has to be initiated by law enforcement
or a member of the public not by the
DA's office
sir
um as of October the El Paso sheriffs
have never filed for extreme risk
protection order since the law has been
passed and Colorado Springs PD has filed
two uh my question was for mayor mayor
suthers Chief Vazquez
mayor's others would you like to see
local law enforcement utilize that law
to try to prevent future tragedies and
this tragedy given the previous
interaction that El Paso shares had with
this
change your perspectives on
her so the question was regarding to the
red flag law
and the police department not related to
this investigation but previously had
used that red flag law and then asking
the mayor for his comment regarding the
potentiality of using that law is that a
fair brief okay
my view of the red flag law is that it
was passed by the legislature it's the
law in Colorado and law enforcement
agencies and appropriate circumstances
should take advantage of it and utilize
the law that's my view of it I don't run
a law enforcement agency but that's
would be my advice to law enforcement
agencies I would caution against
an assumption that the circumstance of
this case would lead to application of
the red flag law we don't know that I
wouldn't I would caution any conclusion
uh either way or not I I as the district
attorney indicated hopefully there'll be
a time when there can be a specific
discussion about any prior interaction
with the uh with law enforcement and I
think it would those circumstances would
cause one to be able to
make commentary about potential
application of the red flag law but I
think it's premature to do so now
calling a bomb threat and holding
themselves up in a house and having to
stand up with police would prompt
with extreme risk protection you're
you're assuming that there's credible
evidence of all that as opposed to
someone reporting it and that the
prosecutor had evidence of that and I
would not make assumptions of that
nature